Hey there, Will Arnett here. Welcome to Smart List, our podcast where Jason Bateman, Sean Hayes, and I each week, one of us brings a guest that the other two don't know about. And this week is no exception. We get real into it. Most of the time we just mess around with each other and then the guest has to be embarrassed. So let's get right to the podcast. Hi. Hi, how are you? Good, good. Should we go around the room and just say our names and our roles? Introduce yourself? Yeah, I'm Sean Hayes. People have been listening to the podcast for a minute now. Sorry, so we just skip that. Same three idiots. Okay. In
大家好，我是威尔·阿奈特。欢迎收听《聪明清单》，这是我们的播客节目。在这里，杰森·贝特曼、肖恩·海斯和我，我们三个人每周都会邀请一位其他两人都不知道的神秘嘉宾。这周也不例外。我们要动真格的了。大多数时候我们只是互相开玩笑，然后让嘉宾感到尴尬。所以我们直接进入正题吧。嗨。嗨，你好吗？很好，很好。我们要不要围着屋子一圈，只说出我们的名字和角色？自我介绍一下？好吧，我是肖恩·海斯。大家听这个播客已经有一会儿了。抱歉，那我们就跳过这个吧。还是那三个笨蛋。好吧。在
the role of Sean Hayes is Sean Hayes. Should we switch parts today? Oh, we could switch parts. Oh, yeah. I'll play Will. I'll play Will. What about that? You guys are assholes. Fuck. Oh, God. Okay. I'm going to be Jason. It's hard for me though. So when I look back and I think about all the things that you've done, let's start at the beginning. Okay, so America was founded in 1492. But what if I want to really be understood? No one understands me in my house. You know, I've got a wife and two girls that just, I start talking, they glaze over. So I really have to fight for attention. I get on this thing. I feel like I've got to stop describing my question, right? We've spoken about this before and
扮演肖恩·海斯角色的是肖恩·海斯。我们今天要不要换角色？哦，我们可以换角色。哦，对。我来演威尔。我来演威尔。怎么样？你们这群混蛋。操。哦，天哪。好吧。我要当杰森。不过这对我来说很难。所以当我回想并思考你所做过的一切时，让我们从头开始。好吧，所以美国是在1492年被发现的。但如果我想真正被理解呢？我在家里没有人理解我。你知道的，我有一个妻子和两个女儿，我一开始说话，她们就眼神呆滞了。所以我真的必须为争取注意力而战。我上了这个节目。我觉得我得停止描述我的问题了，对吧？我们以前谈过这个，并且
I just need to ask the question. And then Sean, and then Sean's like a golden, Sean comes on and he's like, do you like whipped cream? What's your favorite color? If Will was a dog, what kind of dog would Will be on this podcast? Oh God, that's a good question. Will's probably like an untrained German shepherd. But messy, matted. Yeah, just drool coming out on the side. Bad hips like the German shepherds get. Yeah, dysplasia. Yeah. Jesus, they would be like a full size standard, but shaved poodle. So cold yet fancy. And very proud walks. Very proud. Anyway, let's get to our guests, please. Yeah, let's do it. And I'm going to tell you, you guys actually know this person, but we're going to find
我只需要问这个问题。然后肖恩，然后肖恩就像一个金子般的，肖恩上来说，你喜欢鲜奶油吗？你最喜欢的颜色是什么？如果威尔是一只狗，在这档播客里威尔会是什么种类的狗？哦天哪，这是个好问题。威尔可能就像一只未经训练的德国牧羊犬。但很邋遢，毛发纠结。对，就是嘴边流着口水。像德国牧羊犬那样髋关节不好。对，发育不良。对，天哪，它们会像一只标准体型但被剃了毛的狮子狗。既高冷又别致。而且走路非常骄傲。非常骄傲。不管怎样，请让我们迎请我们的嘉宾吧。对，我们开始吧。我要告诉你们，你们其实认识这个人，但我们要挖掘
out stuff that we don't know about this person. If it's my mom, I'm in trouble because I haven't called her for a while. Can I just say, if it's your mom, what? Careful. This would be such a... Careful. No, I'm just going to say it would be such a mitzvah. If it was your mom, because we could really get into... There's so much stuff about you and we've known each other a long time that I want to know. You know whose mom is not going to come on mine because she's dead. So that's our first commercial break. We're going to go to a florist commercial break right now. Sean, by the way, I will say your mom is dead, but imagine if my surprise guest was your mom. That would really... That would be more surprising
我们不了解的关于这个人的事情。如果是我妈妈，我就麻烦了，因为我已经有一段时间没给她打电话了。我能说吗，如果那是你妈妈，什么？小心点。这会是一个……小心点。不，我只是想说这会是一个大恩德。如果那是你妈妈，因为我们真的可以深入……关于你有很多事情，而且我们认识很久了，我很想知道。你知道谁的妈妈不会来我的节目，因为她已经去世了。所以这是我们的第一个商业广告时间。我们现在要进入一个花店广告时间。肖恩，顺便说一下，我会说你妈妈去世了，但想象一下，如果我的惊喜嘉宾是你妈妈。那真的……那会比
than me being pale. Pailer than me, my God. Guys, our guest today is from Irvine, California. His mom was a teacher and his father played sax and keyboard for the righteous brothers. Do we get a chance to guess at any point? No. Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. No, don't guess because he studied sports journalism at USC, but ultimately went on to join the Groundlings and the rest is history. He's got like a million movies under his belt and I'm sure that's not the only thing. Ladies and gentlemen, William Ferrell. Oh my God. Jason. There's his head shot. Jason. Hi, Jason. Jason, answer the belly. Jason, it's your mother. First of all, she's British, Will. Oh, okay. Sorry. But let me guess, let
我脸色苍白还要令人惊讶。比我还苍白，我的天哪。伙计们，我们今天的嘉宾来自加州欧M.I.尔湾。他的母亲是一名教师，他的父亲为正义兄弟合唱团演奏萨克斯和键盘。我们有没有机会在某个时刻猜一下？没有。哦，等等，等等，等等，等等。不，不要猜，因为他在南加州大学学习体育新闻，但最终加入了格罗夫林斯剧团，剩下的就是历史了。他腰缠万贯，拍了大约上百万部电影，我确信还不止这些。女士们先生们，威廉·法瑞尔。哦，天哪。杰森。这是他的大头照。杰森。嗨，杰森。杰森，接电话。杰森，是你母亲。首先，她是个英国人，威尔。哦，好吧。抱歉。但让我猜，让
me guess and let me guess and that. Oh, what a great booking, Sean. Congratulations. Guys, can I just, can I start by saying I'm so excited to be on the gong show podcast, all things you want to know about the new gong show. And it is just, I mean, it's sweeping that country, both countries, Canada and US. Aren't that taking fire? It's unbelievable. Are you just drinking, is that just medicine out of the bottle? That's what it looks like. It's a kombucha. I know that because my wife drinks those. But it does look like a tonic from the old time tonic. Yeah. And I just, I drink it as a prophylactic. Sure. Yeah. Well Ferrell, thank you so much for coming on our little show. My pleasure. And we're
我猜，让我猜那个。哦，多棒的预约啊，肖恩。祝贺你。伙计们，我能，我能先说我很高兴能来到这个“锣声秀”播客，所有你想知道关于新“锣声秀”的事情。而且它真的是，我是说，它正在席卷这个国家，两个国家，加拿大和美国。难道不是正在火热进行吗？这真是难以置信。你是在喝酒吗，那瓶子里装的只是药吗？看起来就是那样。那是康普茶。我知道是因为我妻子喝那种东西。但它看起来确实像老式的补药。对。我喝它纯粹是为了预防。当然。好吧，威廉·法瑞尔，非常感谢你能来我们的这个小节目。我的荣幸。我们
all obviously such gigantic fans of yours. And one question, you know, you know, you're one of the rare people in this business and I think I can speak on behalf of everybody that, you know, it's really hard to find people like you. Hold on one second. Will Ferrell's got a phone call. Yes. Tight five everybody. Okay, that's a large pepperoni, right? Oh, do you want chicken fingers with that? I thought he was ordering. He's taking orders. Can I get the, oh, all right. Okay. All right, Todd, we'll be there in 35 minutes. He asked for the address and then he knew the guy. So we didn't need the address. Hey, hey, keep your landlines, folks. Keep your landlines. It is pretty strong. That looks almost like your
显然都是你超级无敌的粉丝。还有一个问题，你知道的，你是这个行业中罕见的人之一，我想我可以代表所有人说，你知道的，很难找到像你这样的人。等一下。威廉·法瑞尔有电话。好的，大家给五分钟。好吧，那是超级大号意式辣香肠披萨，对吧？哦，你要鸡柳吗？我以为他在点单。他在接单。我能点个，哦，好吧。好吧。好吧，托德，我们35分钟后到。他问了地址，然后他认识那个人。所以我们不需要地址。嘿，嘿，大家留着固定电话。留着固定电话。这酒挺烈的。看起来几乎就像你的
banking system collapse. You're going to want to have a landline. What I was going to say, William, was Ferrell was, I always wanted to know what is that one thing or that one event or that one person that made you want to get in the business and pursue comedy? What was that? Barack Obama. Correct. What? Before that, before that. Great answer. Just like a week before that. The one thing, the one person? Yeah, was there like a show or a person or an event or something in your family or? Oh, Jesus. This is supposed to be things you don't know. You're coming waterworks. Yeah. And we are losing light. We're losing light. I said I wouldn't cry. You said you wouldn't try to get me to cry, Sean, but
银行系统崩溃了。你会想要有一部固定电话的。我本来想说的是，威廉，是法瑞尔，我一直想知道，到底是什么事情、什么事件或什么人让你想要进入这个行业并追求喜剧？那是什么？巴拉克·奥巴马。正确。什么？在此之前，在此之前。好答案。就在那之前大约一个星期。那件事，那个人？对，是不是有什么节目、或者某个人、或者某个事件、或者你家庭里的什么事？哦，天哪。这本该是谈论你们不知道的事情。你把眼泪都勾出来了。对。而且我们在失去光线。我们在失去光线。我说过我不会哭。你说过你不会试图弄哭我的，肖恩，但
right out of the gate. Here's the real answer to your question. Yeah. I enjoyed being funny as a child, but I was actually diametrically opposed to going into entertainment because I watched my father, the musician, go from job to job and be fired at the drop of a hat and I thought, who would want to do that? I'm going to have a job where I carry a briefcase to work. I can relate to that. I had some of the same fears myself, yet I still went into this non-meritocracy and fickle sort of industry. You were early. You were early child. Right, but you were young as well, but I mean not a child, but you had an opportunity to take a different path, yet you didn't. You couldn't resist the allure of the pancake
一上来就来了。这就是你问题的真正答案。对。我小时候觉得搞笑很有趣，但我实际上是坚决反对进入娱乐业的，因为我看着身为音乐家的父亲工作换了一份又一份，说被解雇就被解雇，我想，谁会想那样做呢？我要找一份提着公文包去上班的工作。我对此深有同感。我自己也有过同样的恐惧，但我还是进入了这个非精英统治且变化无常的行业。你很小。你很小的时候。对，但你当时也很年轻，我的意思是虽然不是小孩子，但你有机会选择一条不同的路，然而你却没有。你无法抗拒煎饼
makeup. Yeah, so what about that though? The floor lights. After seeing your dad. Are there still floor lights? Yeah, they're scoop lights. Scoop lights. Yeah, yeah, scoop. Yeah, scoop. No, okay. Listen, Will, but seeing your dad do that over and over again and not like, you know, travel and not hold down, you know, secure kind of job. So what, if that discouraged you, what encouraged you? I just kind of slowly started incorporating the messing around with my friends, which I'm sure we all did. Keep it clean. Okay, yep. Yeah, okay, you're right. Entertainment of my, ooh, that sounds weird. Yeah. The massage, no. No. Tickle giggle. Tickle giggle. You know, we'd love to have a good gang tickle giggle. That's it.
妆的诱惑。对，那这个呢？舞台灯光。在看到你父亲之后。现在还有舞台灯光吗？对，那是聚光灯。聚光灯。对，对，聚光灯。对，聚光灯。不，好吧。听着，威尔，但是看到你父亲一遍又一遍地那样做，而且不喜欢，你知道的，到处旅行，没有一份稳定的工作。所以，如果那让你感到沮丧，是什么鼓励了你？我只是慢慢开始把和朋友们胡闹结合起来，我确信我们都这样做过。保持干净。好吧，是的。好吧，对，你说的对。娱乐我的，哦，听起来怪怪的。对。按摩，不。不。胳肢咯咯笑。胳肢咯咯笑。你知道，我们很喜欢来一场愉快的群嗨胳肢咯咯笑。就是这样。
We got it. We're back on. No, I just had, high school was kind of the moment, even though I wasn't like a theater kid or anything, and I found myself writing what were essentially skits. But was there like a comedy person that you were like, God, I wish I could do what that guy does or. Who did you think was funny when you were a teenager? I kind of the typical. Interesting that Will Arnett asks at once and gets a response. The pipes. Yeah, it's the pipes. Exactly. I just got down to it. I didn't dress it up with a bunch of BS haze. I was a member of the Columbia house record and tape club and one of one of the items. Oh, you're being serious. I'm being serious for $1 plus postage and handling, which really
我们搞定了。我们回来了。不，我只是觉得，高中可以说是那个时刻，尽管我不是那种戏剧特长生什么的，我发现自己写的基本上都是小品。但有没有哪个喜剧演员让你觉得，天哪，我希望我能像那家伙一样做，或者。当你十几岁的时候，你觉得谁很有趣？我有点像典型的那种。有意思的是，威尔·阿奈特问了一次就得到了回应。这嗓子。对，就是这嗓子。没错。我直接切入正题了。我没有用一堆废话迷雾来装点它。我是哥伦比亚唱片和磁带俱乐部的会员，其中有一项。哦，你是认真的。我是认真的。只要1美元加上邮资和处理费，这实际上
comes out to about a buck 89. That's where they get you. Yeah. I got to choose 13 still seething. It was supposed to be for a penny. You got 13 albums and it's not a penny. It's about 89. Okay. It's the handling that's expensive. We don't work there. It's the postage and the shipping and handling. Yeah. Not to mention, if you get one record a month, if you don't send it back within 14 days, you're charged for it. Yeah. Is that how you still use Netflix? I'm doing it the original way. Yeah, I never, I still get the discs. I'm not streaming. Don't blame you. Will drives by Ted Serrano's house and throws discs at his front door. Here's your fucking movies. I'm done with these. One of my, one of my, it was the cast
算下来大约是1美元89美分。他们就是这么坑你的。对。我可以选13个还在生气的。它本该是一便士的。你得到了13张专辑，而且不是一便士。大约是89美分。好吧。处理费才贵呢。我们不替那儿工作。是邮费、运费和处理费。对。更不用说，如果你一个月买一张唱片，如果你不在14天内退回，你就会被收费。对。你现在还是这样用Netflix的吗？我是用最原始的方式。对，我从来不，我还是买碟片。我不看流媒体。怪不得你。威尔开车经过泰德·塞拉诺的房子，把碟片扔在他的前门上。给你的他妈的电影。我受够这些了。我的其中一个，我的其中一个，它是
album of Saturday Night Live. Okay, great. So you always aspired to be on the show that you were on. I guess quietly. Yes. Quietly. I did. But that's, so Will, so you wanted that and, and hold on. I'm not done. Yeah. I know. Fuck. Will, can I talk to you privately real quick? Yeah. Yeah. No, no, Arnett. Sorry. Listen. Yeah. Listen, Arnett, when the guest is responding to a question, especially one that you cut him off for Christ's sake. No, no, wait until the silence, silence follows a completion of the fucking answer. Here we go. Okay. Steve Martin, Steve Martin. Yep. And then I was also a tonight show weirdo. I'd stay up and wait to see who the comedian was. If there was a comedian on that night,
《周六夜现场》的演员专辑。哦，太棒了。所以你一直渴望加入那个你曾参与的节目。我猜是默默地。是的。默默地。我是的。但这，所以威尔，所以你想要那个，并且，等一下。我还没说完呢。对。我知道。操。威尔，我能私下跟你说个话吗？对。对。不，不，阿奈特。抱歉。听着。对。听着，阿奈特，当嘉宾正在回答问题时，特别是那种被你打断的问题，看在上帝的份上。不，不，等到沉默，在那个他妈的回答完成后再沉默。我们开始吧。好吧。史蒂夫·马丁，史蒂夫·马丁。对。然后我还是个《今夜秀》怪胎。我会熬夜等着看喜剧演员是谁。如果那天晚上有喜剧演员，
I'd watch. If there wasn't, I'd turn it off. Wow. So I was kind of, that's how I, so those are the guys, Steve Martin, also an idol of mine too is comedy wise. I just thought, right. So, so dry and brilliant. But what was that moment? So you, you grew up in Orange County, you go to USC and then you go to groundlings. What is that gap between when you, I never knew this, like from when you finished USC to groundlings. What was that gap? Like how did you, so I graduate USC with a degree in sports journalism. So in my mind's eye, I'm going to go work on a ESPN, you know, I'm going to be a, a sports caster and Oh, that would have been great. I know. I blew it. And missed it. In fact, Craig Kilburn
我会看。如果没有，我就关掉。哇。所以我有点，这就是我，所以那些人，史蒂夫·马丁，同样也是我的偶像，在喜剧方面。我只是觉得，没错。所以，那么干瘪而精彩。但那是什么时刻？所以你，你在橙县长大，你去上南加州大学，然后你去格罗夫林斯剧团。从你毕业到去格罗夫林斯剧团之间，那段空白期是什么？我从来不知道这个，就像从你完成南加州大学到格罗夫林斯剧团。那段空白期是什么样的？你是怎么，我从南加州大学毕业，拿的是体育新闻学位。所以在我的脑海里，我要去ESPN工作，你知道的，我要成为一个体育播音员，哦，那太棒了。我知道。我搞砸了。错过了。事实上，克雷格·基尔伯恩
brings that up to me every day. Do you remember Craig Kilburn? Sure do. Do you have a, do you have an ongoing friendship with Craig Kilburn? I haven't seen him in probably 15 years. No. Well, he's on next. Come on out, Craig. You'll see him in the green room on your way out. If you were quarantining with Craig Kilburn, that would be it for me. That would be the greatest. So, so you finish. So yeah. So I have this, I finish and then I start doing my, I mean, there wasn't really a job placement program coming out of college. And so you kind of have to figure out a way. I found like a local Orange County cable access news station that I started working at and I was trying to put
每天都把这事提起来。你还记得克雷格·基尔伯恩吗？当然记得。你和克雷格·基尔伯恩有长期的友谊吗？我大概有15年没见过他了。没有。好吧，他下一个出场。出来吧，克雷格。你走的时候在化妆室会看到他的。如果你要和克雷格·基尔伯恩一起隔离，对我来说那就是极限了。那将是最棒的。所以，所以你毕业了。所以，是的。我有这个，我毕业了，然后我开始做我的，我的意思是，大学毕业后并没有真正的就业安置计划。所以你得自己想办法。我找到了当地的一个橙县有线电视新闻台，我开始在那里工作，我正试图拼凑
together a tape, which I wish we could cut to that now, that in which, yeah, I did, you know, sort of do some field reporting and you would, you would anchor the news. You'd also work the camera. You would do everything. And there was a light bulb moment in that, even though it was this small rinky dink local cable access, they had legitimate press credentials to all the major sports teams in LA. And at that time, the Rams, the LA Rams football team were playing down at Anaheim Stadium. And the editor, you know, of the show, which was actually a teacher of the class, it was actually run out of a junior college. He said, hey, we need someone to go interview John Robinson, the head coach of the Rams at the
一段录像带，我真希望我们现在能切到那个画面，我在那里面，是的，我确实做了一些现场报道，你要播报新闻。你还要操作摄像机。你什么都做。这其中有一个醍醐灌顶的时刻，尽管这只是一个小型破烂的当地有线电视台，但他们拥有洛杉矶所有主要球队的合法记者证。当时，洛杉矶公羊队（LA Rams）橄榄球队正在阿纳海姆体育场比赛。节目的剪辑师，实际上也是那个班级的老师，那个课程实际上是在一所初级学院开办的，他说，嘿，我们需要有人在这个周末的比赛结束后去体育场采访公羊队的主教练约翰·罗宾逊。
stadium after this weekend's game. And 40 hands shot up, except for mine. But you knew him from SC, yeah? No, no, no, I'd never met him. But, but, uh, the point was here we're, I'm surrounded by these hungry people who were like, I need that interview on my reel. And my first thought was like, I'm going to have to check out a camera. I got to ask someone, yeah, parking, I got to pay for it. I got to ask one of my classmates that they'll run sound for me. Yeah, and you don't have a lot of money from, you don't have a lot of money left over from that subscription to all those from Columbia. Yeah, no, I'm in debt from Columbia house, representing. He's in the middle of a major lawsuit against
40只手举了起来，除了我的。但你从南加州大学就认识他，对吧？不，不，不，我从来没见过他。但是，但是，重点是，我们，我被这些饥饿的人包围着，他们说，我需要在我的作品集里有那个采访。我的第一反应是，我得去借一台摄像机。我还得找个人，对，停车位，我还得付钱。我得找一个同班同学帮我收音。对，而且你从哥伦比亚的所有订阅里剩的钱不多了。对，没钱了。是的，我欠着哥伦比亚唱片的债，代表。他正处于对哥伦比亚唱片公司的一场重大诉讼之中。我们，我们已经推进到五码线了，伙计们。如果当我们最终达成协议时，请让我再次上节目，我会把所有的钱都捐给慈善机构，但是天哪，我们要狠狠地打击他们。但我没有，我没有，我说，这不是个好兆头。我本应该从椅子上跳起来，去真正采访一位NFL的主教练，把它放进我的作品集里，这样我就能在亚利桑那州尤马的一个电台找到工作。我说，如果我没有，我真的没有那种驱动力，那么另一件一直在折磨我的事情就是，我真的应该考虑一下这个喜剧的事情。所以，那就是我报名参加格罗夫林斯剧团第一节课的时候。
Columbia. We are, we are on the five yard line, guys. And if please have me on next, when we finally come to terms, but I'm giving all the money to charity, but God, we're going to hammer them. But I had no, I had no, I said, this is not a good sign. I should be leaping out of my chair to go and actually get a legit interview with a head football coach from the NFL on my reel so that I can get hired at a, you know, station in Yuma, Arizona. And I said, if I don't, I don't really have that drive, then this other thing that's kind of still gnawing away at me is I should really be looking into this comedy thing. So I, that's when I signed up for my first class at the groundlings.
真的吗？是的。我不是在催促你这么做。在那之后多久，你通过扮演哈里·凯瑞把这两件事结合起来的？哦，那是，是的，那大约在中间。那是几年后，在棒球罢工期间，这简直快把我笑死了。哦，那是你在格罗夫林斯剧团做的一个角色。对。对。当时是，当时是棒球罢工，我以前，我有一份工作，在我当时的朋克、现在的主妇维维卡曾经工作过的一个艺术拍卖行里。我是拍卖行的估价协调员，基本上就是，我接电话，协调估价并打印估价单。哇。而且在好几次场合面临被解雇的威胁。但我，
Really? Yeah. I'm not trying to prod you into doing it. How soon after that did you kind of braid the two things by working on your Harry carry? Oh, that was, yeah, that was kind of midway. That was a couple of years later during the baseball strike and just kills me. Oh, that was a character you did at groundlings. Yeah. Yeah. There was, it was the baseball strike and I used to, I had, I had a job, the art auction house that my then friend now wife Vivica used to work at. I was the appraisal coordinator at the auction house, which was basically, I answered the phones and coordinated appraisals and typed up appraisals. Wow. And was, was threatened to be fired on several occasions. But I would,
我住得离家够近，午饭可以开车回家，白天我会把小熊队的比赛打开。我以前从未听说过哈里·凯瑞。我就想，这是谁？这人是谁？对，我在芝加哥长大。所以他是我们生活的一部分。一个常驻人物。没错。所以我就，我一直在听。让我震惊的是，听一场比赛，听这个播音员在全国联合广播电视上说：如果那个球是个好球，我就是中国佬。而我，我，我真的差点把水喷出来，心想，他刚刚是不是说中国佬？等等，等等，等等，等等，这是一个拿钱做这事的人。他就像是，所以我没有，没有，我只是想，不，这，这肯定是个小品。
I lived close enough home to drive home for lunch and I would turn the Cubs games on during the day. And I had never heard of Harry carry. And I was like, who is this? Who is this guy? Yeah, I grew up in Chicago. So he was a part of our lives. A fixture. Right. And so I'm just, I would be listening. And the thing that struck me was listening to a game and listening to this announcer say on syndicated national television. If that ball's a strike, I'm a Chinaman. And I, I, I literally did like a spit take and was like, did he just say Chinaman? Wait, wait, wait, wait, this is like a guy who's paid to do this. He's like, and so I not, not, I just thought, no, this is, this has got to be a sketch somehow.
然后，他们，所以不知怎么的，尽管那是南加州观众，我写了一个小品，那是在棒球罢工期间。所以哈里·凯瑞没有比赛可以播报，他不知怎么地参与了当地一家剧院的话剧排练。这是一部，这是一部情节剧。他们只是坐在一起，你知道的，我们从第一幕开始。然后，你知道的，佩里的台词是这样的：该死的，卡罗尔。为什么我们做爱的时候你从来不看着我？然后，我，然后到最后，到最后小品结束时，观众们笑得直不起腰，尽管他们根本不知道哈里·凯瑞是个真人。这是一件超越了
And they, they, so I somehow, even though it was a Southern California audience, I wrote a sketch where it was during the baseball strike. So Harry carry didn't have games to announce and he would, he had somehow gotten involved in a play reading in a local theater. And it was this, this melodramatic play. And they were just sitting around, you know, let's take it from Act One. And it was, you know, Perry had lines like, God damn it, Carol. Why don't you ever look at me when we make love? And I, I, and by the end, by the end of the sketch, the audience was like doubling over and laughter, even though they, they had no idea that Harry carry was a real person. This is something that's transcending, you
你知道的。顺便说一下，顺便说一下，从来不知道这一点，当然，你演了那么多场哈里·凯瑞的角色，但让他做某事的想法，它总是在棒球的背景下，但看到他做一些完全脱离……哦，是的。而且，我们剧团里还有其他所有演员，我们有一个非常好的剧团，每个人都演得极其正经。就像这个女演员，玛吉·加德，在读台词时真的把自己弄哭了，而且，而且就像是，你的眼泪
know, Yeah. By the way, by the way, never knowing that, of course, you do the Harry carry characters so many times, but the idea of him doing something, it was always in the baseball context, but seeing him doing something that's completely out of. Oh yeah. And, and we had all these other actors in our, we had a really good troupe and everyone was just playing it perfectly straight. And like this one actress, Maggie Baird was literally getting herself to cry while she read it. And, and, and it was just like, your tears
对我毫无意义。自从我们走过圣坛的那天起，这个婚姻就破裂了。你知道的，总是有点醉，对吧？对。对。就是，然后，还有点颤抖。然后我的朋友罗伊作为导演说：好了，到此为止。哈里，我不知道我有没有感觉到，你知道的，只是给出表演指导，然后就像，哈里，我这次真的很想从你身上感受到那种情绪。你现在在场景中除了卡罗尔谁也不对讲话。好吧，我们再来一次。然后，就是开始又停下，那个。你做SNL试镜时演过哈里吗？演过，事实上，我试过演一个加强版的。而且太超现实了，因为，你知道，你只是在一个，你只是在一个虚空中。你在，你在那个录音室的8-H里。天哪，你当时一定紧张极了。我要是一团糟就好了。我只记得在等待，在通道里等待，所以你们都知道那里的设置，
mean nothing to me. This marriage has been broken since the day we crossed the altar. You know, Always kind of drunk, right? Yeah. Yeah. Just, and then, And quaking a little And then my friend Roy was the director like, okay, let's stop there. Harry, I don't know if I'm feeling, you know, just giving the acting notes and like, Harry, I really want to feel it from you this time. And you're speaking to no one but Carol right now in
在演播室门外的传达台旁等着，听着排在你前面的人做他们的试镜，而你正在候场，看着周围所有刚刚主持过节目的名人的照片。身处你梦想中的地方，而现在你就在那里。走到一个漆黑一片的演播室里，除了聚光灯、摄像机、挑杆收音员，还有坐在阴影里的洛恩。然后你必须在虚空中进行喜剧表演或者站着，可能吧。所以，是的，那非常超现实。我试着演了。我不知道。威廉·法瑞尔，我还想知道，比如，你有没有渴望过做点别的？我知道你想成为一名体育播音员，对吧？一个体育解说员，但是如果你，如果你没有做你现在做的事，不是隔离期间，而是在娱乐行业里，你会做什么？如果你必须选择一份蓝领工作，你必须选，会是什么？哦，蓝领。我当时，因为我要说的是，我一直想做金融。它对你来说似乎很有趣。我喜欢金融。我喜欢弄明白哪怕多一秒钟的，你知道的，我都无法完成这个包袱，因为我甚至不知道这些术语，但是对，refi，低，威尔复活了。当你提到私募股权时，就像是，谁说的，你是次贷吗？那还是一回事吗？我其实可以成为一个，我其实可以做一个邮递员，
the scene. Okay, let's take it again. And, and just the starting and stopping of that. And Did you do Harry when you did your SNL audition? I did, which was, in fact, I tried to do an augmented version of that. And it was so surreal because, you know, you're just in a, you're just in a void. You're on, you're in 8-H in the studio there. God, you must have been so nervous. I would have been just a mess. I just remember listening, waiting in the way, so you guys all know that setup there,
说实话，去送信，因为我喜欢，喜欢那种路线的设想，而且你可以，你知道的，和人们有一些接触，还有每天完成一项任务的想法。你会带着狗喷雾剂步行武装吗？还是你会坐在小推车里？我会步行，推着手推车。我推手推车。不错。是的。不错。那些，那些很狡猾棘手。那三个轮子的东西，它们会从你身上翻过去。我确信它们会，是的。在大风中，或者，或者，或者如果你不把信拿出来，你不按顺时针或逆时针方向旋转。如果你从左边拿走太多，它就会向右倾斜，反之亦然。你以前做过吗？嘿，你有多经常看着窗外对着邮递员手淫，很多还是很少？只有在他们穿短裤的夏季。看那个车。那是大卫。那是大卫。我们的邮递员大卫来了。是的，大卫要翻了。
waiting by the page desk outside the doors of the studio and hearing the person ahead of you go through their audition while you're on deck and just looking at all the famous pictures of everyone who had just hosted. And being in the spot, in the place that you dreamed of being and now you're there. Getting out to a studio that's pitch black, except for a spotlight and a camera and a boom operator and Lauren sitting in the shadows. And then you just have to do comedy or standing in a void, possibly. So yeah, that was very surreal. I tried doing it. I don't know. Will Ferrell, I also want to know, like, have you ever desired to do anything? I know you
大卫，要翻了。我去拿信。嘿，伙计们，大卫来了。是不是？等等。切到反打。没有人。没有人。他孤身一人。嘿，贝特曼，问个快问题。因为你做过，我们之前提到你是在娱乐圈长大的，我们都知道我们看过那些伟大的作品，现在正在收听的人，可以立刻用谷歌搜索像《草原上的小屋》这样的节目，看到可爱的小杰森·贝特曼。是的。你有没有过真正的，你有没有过像娱乐圈之外的工作？你有没有过像？我没有，我真的很讨厌这一点。我宁愿有一个类似戴夫那样开着三轮车的送报路线。但你小时候一直在工作。我10岁就开始了。是的。所以没有机会，但我一直理所当然地幻想过
wanted to be a sports announcer, right? A sportscaster, but as if you, if you weren't doing the thing that you're doing, not quarantining, but in entertainment business, what would you be doing? If you had to pick a blue collar job, you had to pick, what would it be? Oh, blue collar. I was, because I was going to say, I've always wanted to do finance. It seems so interesting to you. I love finance. I love figuring out like a second more, you know, I can't even do the bit because I don't even know the terms, but right, refi, low will comes alive. When you mentioned private equity, it's like, who said, are you subprime? Is that still a thing? I actually could be a, I could actually be a post person to be
端盘子或当调酒师。有些关于为小费工作的感受，有点像我想让他们喜欢我的那种感觉。我希望这张桌子可能需要一些和那张桌子不同的东西，只是为了能够变幻成他们需要的任何样子。我有，我必须这么说，我所有所谓的平民工作我都做得很糟糕。所以。因为你不喜欢权威，或者你只是不感兴趣。你知道的，比如反应迟钝。是的。就像反应慢半拍。我有很多有耐心的经理和主管，他们。你有很多工作吗？比如，你在高中有做过什么奇怪的工作吗？我从来没有，我一直在做运动。所以，但我有，你知道的，我有那种，我在银行当过出纳。我当过代客泊车员。你是怎么接受管理的？好吧，你知道，银行出纳，你知道的，有些规章制度你必须遵守，诸如此类。这花了我一些时间。我的意思是，我处理数字和金钱的事实，这简直让我。这简直让人欣喜若狂，因为金融。
quite honest to deliver the mail because I like, like the idea of a route and you get to, you know, have some contact with people and the idea of finishing a task every day. Would you be on foot armed with the, with the dog spray? Or would you be in the buggy? I would go, I would go foot with the trolley. I'd push the trolley. Nice. Yeah. Nice. Those are, those are sneaky tricky. Those three wheels thing, they will go over on you. I'm sure they, yeah. In a high wind or yeah. Or if, or if you don't take the letters out, you don't go in a clockwise or counterclockwise rotation. If you take too many out of the left side, it's going to tip over on the right
我的意思是，这促成了我对金融的热爱，但我，我，我曾经有一个老顾客在交易进行到一半时拦住我，说：你能把你的经理叫过来吗？我说：当然。我把她叫了过来，当着我的面，他说：这家伙是你最差的出纳。好吧。我只想让你知道这一点。他以一种非常平静的方式说。他说：看，看他现在。他在冒汗。我当时确实在冒汗，他说：他太糟糕了。他花的时间太长了。他，而且，经理为了维护他，说：请，那，那不是真的。我当时想：不，他说的有点对。我只想让你知道，我讨厌去他的窗口。然后他就
and vice versa. Did you used to do it? Hey, how often did you look out the window masturbating at the postman a lot or a little? Only in the summer months when they wear the shorts. Look at that cart. There's David. There's David. David, our postman's here. Yeah. David is going to topple. David, it's going to topple. I'll get the mail. Hey guys, David's here. Yes or what? Wait. Cut to the reverses. Nobody's there. Nobody's there. He's alone. Hey Bateman, quick question.
走开了。她说：真抱歉。我说：你知道吗，我真的没法跟他争论。我，我确实不是个好出纳。这是在数钞票，数现金还是，你知道的，全干，兑现支票，聊天。对，全干。所以从长远来看，那家伙帮了你一个忙，对吧？在很多方面。听起来你需要给某人写封信。好吧，每次我去，每次我化上煎饼妆，我脑海里就会浮现那个家伙的画面，然后我说：现在谁在笑？所以你还是自己化所有的妆？
Cause you did, we mentioned before you grew up in showbiz, we all know that we've seen the great things and people who are listening can, can right now Google up like little house in the prairie and see cute little Jason Bateman. Yeah. Did you ever have a real, did you ever have like an outside show business job? Have you ever had like a? I didn't and I genuinely hate that. I'd love to have had a paper route similar to Dave's route with his three wheeler. But you were working all the time as a kid. I started at 10. Yeah. So there was no chance to, but I've always legitimately fantasized
我坚持这么做。这太疯狂了。好吧，有过敏问题，尤其是在我们都将步入的后COVID-19时代。我绝对会自己化所有的妆。所以威廉·法瑞尔，你是这个星球上最搞笑的人之一，如果不是最搞笑的人的话。每个人都，你是否厌倦了，因为现在你是一个父母，你必须出席学校活动和孩子的家长活动。人们总是对你抱有这种期望吗？你的反应是什么？有一种程度的让人大失所望。这是一个词吗？
about waiting tables or bartending. There's something about working for a tip, which is sort of like the same thing as I want them to like me. I want this table, might need something different than that table to just sort of like being able to morph into whatever they need me to be. I have, I do, I will say this, all my quote unquote civilian jobs I've been pretty terrible at. So. Because you didn't like authority or you were just disinterested. You know, like slow. Yeah. Just like slow on the uptake. I had a lot of patient managers
是的。是的。现在是了。我看得出来，我看得出来有很多不断失望的人。但威尔，我要这么说，你知道，威尔，我不记得几年前了，也许去年我们在吃晚饭。是的。我们和里希特以及皮特·吉尔斯一起吃晚饭，你和维维卡从一个
and supervisors who. Did you have a lot of jobs? Like, do you have weird jobs in high school that you did? I never, I was doing sports all the time. So I, but I had, you know, I had like the, I worked as a bank teller. I was a valet Parker of cars. And how are you taking direction? Well, you know, bank teller, you know, there's certain protocols and procedures you have to follow on this and that. And it just took me a while. I mean, the fact that I was handling numbers and money is, it just, I was like. It was euphoric because of the, the, the finance.
学校活动回来。是的。还有其他几对父母。威尔当时戴着他的名牌，他们都戴着名牌，威尔说：你好，我叫威尔，在那个牌子上，这真的很好，这充分证明了你是一个多么棒的人。这就像是，是的，伙计，我不是来这儿的。我来这儿只是因为我的孩子在这里上学，我关心我的孩子、他们的生活和他们的学校。但我确信你们也面临着同样的事情。我发现更多的是，有些父母
I mean, that's, that led to my love finance, but I, I, I once had a, a regular customer stop me in the middle of a transaction and say, can you call your manager over? And I said, sure. And I brought her over and he's, and in front of me, he said, this guy is your worst teller. Okay. And I just want you to know this. And he did in a very calm way. And he was like, look, look at him right now. He's sweating. And I literally was sweating and he's like, he's terrible. He takes forever. He, and, and the manager to her defense was like, please, that's, that's not true. And I was like, no, he's kind of right. And I just want you to know, like, I hate when I have to go to his window. And then he just
甚至不会打招呼，因为他们走得太极端了。是的。我不想打扰他们。所以你会想：嘿，你好吗？然后他们径直走过去，心想：天哪，我，我说错什么了吗？是的。是的。然后你会觉得，在相反的一面，你是否觉得有时你不得不表现出一种不那么友好、或者不那么渴望对话的氛围？因为你害怕如果你表现得太友好了，他们真的会
walked away. And she was like, I'm sorry about that. I was like, I, you know what, I can't really argue with him. There's a, I'm not that great a teller. This was counting bills, counting out cash or, you know, everything, cashing a cheque chat. Yeah, do it all. So that guy did you a favor in the long run, right? In a lot of ways. Sounds like you need to pen someone a letter. Well, every time I go, every time I put the pancake makeup on, and I picture that guy, and I say, who's laughing now? So you still do all your own makeup.
凑上来。比如你该如何我会说，不，我会说，至少在学校环境里，大多数人都是，是，是相对正常的。我会说，那种姿态，那是我坐商业航班时的游戏面孔。对。就是，就是酸溜溜的。离我远点。我会撕碎你的头。我可不是来这里寻欢作乐的。赶紧飞吧。
I insist on it. It's crazy. Well, there's allergies, especially in the, you know, post COVID-19 world we're all about to step into. I will definitely be doing all my own makeup. So Will Ferrell, you are one of the funniest people on the planet, if not the funniest person on the planet. And everybody kind of, do you get sick of like, because now you're a parent and you have to show up to like school things and parent things for your kids. Do people expect that from you all the time? And what is your reaction? There is a certain level of underwhelment. Is that a word?
眼罩和耳机。威尔，有什么你还没做过但你想做的事吗？比如你想扮演的角色或者？没了。回聊。完全满足。我怎么，我怎么把这个摄像机机关掉？我怎么从这儿出去？不，没有，因为每个人都认为你能做任何事。
Yes. Yeah. It is now. I can tell, I can tell there are a lot of let down people continually. But Will, I will say this, you know, Will, I don't even remember this a couple of years ago, maybe last year we were having dinner. Yeah. We were having dinner with with Richter and Pete Giles and you and Viv came in from a
我不知道。但你如何，你如何，你不能不说得像个混蛋就给出这个答案。对。好吧，是的，你会怎么做，如果，比如说，雷德利·斯科特来找你，他想拍一部《李尔王》，他只是觉得他在你身上看到了某种东西，会让你觉得就像是，不可思议，这是不符合你一向风格的，工作室也很兴奋，所有这些术语，所有这些东西，片酬就像是，不，就像你从未有过，等等等等等等。你的混蛋雷达会响吗，然后说，尽管你能做到，但你觉得观众永远不会接受它？
school event. Yeah. And with a couple other parents. And Will was wearing his name tag, they're all wearing name tags and will say, hello, my name is Will on the thing, which is, which is great. And that's such a testament to what a great guy you are. And it's like, yeah, man, I'm not here. I'm just here because my kids are at school here and I'm interested in my kids and their lives and their school. But I'm sure you guys face the same thing. I find more that there are some parents who
对。我认为要说服自己你能胜任那个角色，会是一件难事。话虽如此，你有，你有《李尔王》，你打算，杰森，你是导演吗？你在拍吗？没有，但是你，但是实事求是地说？我认为你把你所做的事情拿出来，把它推向了那么多现实的、戏剧性的、忧郁的事情，真的没有人能做到这一点，就像没有人能像你在喜剧中那样。我真的认为这令人钦佩，你是如何如此清楚地知道自己给人的印象是什么，你的目标在哪里，以及你的，
literally won't say hi because they go so far the other way. Yeah. I don't, I don't want to bother them. So then you're like, hey, how you doing? And then they walk right by and like, gosh, what, what did I say something wrong? Yeah. Yeah. And then do you feel on the, on the opposite of that, do you feel that you have to sometimes lead with sort of a vibe that is less than sort of friendly or less than sort of solicitous of conversation? Because you're afraid that if you seem too friendly, they're really going
嗯，你是在要求观众接受你作为我想，那是很有纪律性的。我很欣赏这一点。但是，是的，我的意思是，做那些别的东西很有趣，但有时我会，我总是在那些更严肃的片场说，这，这非常难。而且这很难做到不让你看起来像是在努力成为那个每个人都需要严肃对待的演员。所以这是一张戏剧脸。是的，太，太难了，这太有趣了，因为做，做你做的事，特别是你做的事，威尔，是如此，是如此之难。当我说没有多少人时，就像没有人能做到。你在锻炼吗？对，就是锻炼。好吧，只是你用手臂和
to lean in. And like, how do you kind of I would say, no, I would say that I would say at least in the school setting, most everyone is, is, is relatively normal. I would say that posture, that's my game face for when I'm on a commercial flight. Right. Just, just sour. Don't come near me. I will rip your head off. I will not hear, not here for fun and games. Let's get to flying.
腿做了很多。对。没有人像你那样练腿。你一直这么说。而且不，但是那些姿势，你也总是把它们发出来。很多人不知道，当我来到南加州大学时，威尔训练过雷吉·布什。我是一个相当谦逊的人。我想你们，我想这在这里表现出来了，但我不会退缩。没有人能像我那样练腿。我的意思是，练腿日在法瑞尔家就像是一个节日。练腿日是，是的，现在还有一件事，威廉·法瑞尔，你知道，你不仅被称为世界上最搞笑的人，而且也是最善良的人之一，行业里的每个人都对你赞不绝口，认为你是一个多么棒的人。这就是难点所在。我无法证明这一点
Eye mask and headphones. Well, is there anything that you haven't done that you want to do? Either a role that you want to play or? Nope. Talk to you later. Totally satisfied. How do I, how do I turn this camera off? How do I get out of here? No, there isn't because everybody thinks you can do anything.
因为那是他们付钱给你的原因。是的，那是他们付钱给你的部分，非常，非常甜美。但是，既然如此，我想我一直想知道的是什么真正惹恼了你。对，我们来了。这就是我们开始采访的地方。他已经康普茶喝得饱饱的了。现在你的意思是，哦，我充满了爱。我们只想要名字。我们只想要名字。对。你上次扯开嗓子大喊大叫并对某人大发雷霆是什么时候？对，因为我想象不出你生气的样子。不，我没有，我不会，我在想那个笑声。我的意思是，我以前尖叫过。我曾以一种专业的方式尖叫过。或者在生活中，或者在家里，或者和人们以及人类在一起，什么惹恼了
I don't know. But how do you, how do you, you can't give that answer without saying like a jackass. Right. Well, yeah, what would you, what would you do if like, let's say, let's say Ridley Scott came to you and he wanted to do a King Lear and he just thought he sees something in you that would just be like an incredibly, it's off brand and studios excited and all of those terms and all of that stuff and the money's just like, no, like you've never, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera. Does your douche meter go off and say, even though you could do it, do you feel like the audience will never accept it?
你？我的意思是，是的，在家里，那是，你知道的，你和孩子们在一起时的典型沮丧。而且出于某种原因，我总是在克制自己，因为我对他们抱有一种标准，我觉得自己当年可没被这么要求过。就像我，我的意思是，我在学校表现不错，但我还是有，你知道的，我的房间一团糟，我从来没倒过洗碗机。但不知为什么，我就是觉得：你们，你们，这并不难。我们只是要求你们倒一下垃圾。看，如果我是你的孩子，我会嘲笑那个然后把垃圾袋放回去。把垃圾袋放回。倒带垃圾桶。你还没完呢。这是一个两步的过程。但那，不知为什么我就会抓狂。然后我就想：这人是谁啊？是的。
Yeah. I think that would be a, that would be a tough one to try to convince yourself that you could pull that one off. Having said that, you have, you have King Lear, are you about to, Jason, are you direct? Are you doing it? No, but you have, but what about in all sincerity? I think you've taken what you do and you've pushed it into so many realistic, dramatic, melancholy things that truly nobody else could do just like no one else could do what you do in comedy. I really think it's admirable how you are so aware of how you come across, what sort of your goal posts are and what you're,
是的。我想如果要说服自己能做到这一点，那会是一个很大的挑战。话虽如此，你有，你有《李尔王》，杰森，你准备，你是导演吗？你在演吗？不，但是你有，但说真的呢？我觉得你把你的所作所为，推向了那么多现实、戏剧化、忧郁的事情，真的没有人能做到，就像没有人能像你一样在喜剧中做那样的事情。我真的觉得很佩服，你对自己给人的第一印象、你的目标是什么以及你的，
well, you're asking the audience to accept you as I think is, that's a lot of discipline. I appreciate that. But yeah, I mean, it's, it's fun to do that other stuff, but there are times where I'm, I am always on those sets of more serious things going, this is, this is very hard. And this is hard to not look like you're trying to be the actor who everyone needs to take serious. So it's a, it's a drama face. Yeah, it's so, it's so tough, which is so funny because doing, doing what you do, specifically what you do will is so, is so hard. And when I say not many people, like nobody could do it. And it's so working out, you mean? Yeah, just work out. Well, just lots of the way you do arms
嗯，你是在要求观众接受你，我认为这需要很大的自律。我很欣赏这一点。但是，是的，我的意思是，做其他事情很有趣，但有时我，我总是在那些更严肃的片场觉得，这，这非常难。这很难让人觉得你不想成为那种每个人都需要认真对待的演员。所以这是一种，这是一种戏剧脸。是的，这太，太难了，这太有趣了，因为做，做你做的事，特别是你做的事，威尔，是如此，是如此之难。当我说没几个人时，就像没有人能做到一样。你是说锻炼吗？是的，就是锻炼。嗯，就是你练手臂的很多方式
and legs. Yeah. Nobody does legs like you. And you've always said that. And no, but the posts, you always post them too. Not a lot of people know that we'll train Reggie Bush when I came through as C. I'm a fairly modest person. I think you guys, I think that comes across here, but I will not hold back. No one does legs the way I do. I mean, leg days is a holiday in the Farrell household. Leg day is, yeah, it's just, now here's the other thing, Will Farrell, you know, you're also known not only as the funniest person in the world, but one of the kindest people and everybody in this business always just raves about what a great human being you are. And that's the hard part. I can't attest to that
和腿。是的。没有人能像你一样练腿。你一直这么说。不，但是那些动态，你总是发出来。很多人不知道，当我来的时候，我会训练雷吉·布什。我是一个相当谦虚的人。我想你们，我想这在这里表现出来了，但我不会退缩。没有人能像我这样练腿。我的意思是，在法瑞尔家里，练腿日就像一个节日。练腿日是，是的，就是，还有一件事，威尔·法瑞尔，你知道，你不仅被称为世界上最搞笑的人，也是最善良的人之一，这个行业的每个人都对你是一个多么好的人赞不绝口。最难的就是这个。我无法证实这一点
because that's what they pay you for. Yeah, that's the part they pay you for very, very sweet. And, but so that said, I think the thing I always wanted to know what really pisses you off. Yeah, here we go. This is where we start the interview. He's all come butchered up. Now do you mean, oh, I'm full of love. We just want names. We just want names. Yeah. When's the last time you just screamed your head off and let somebody had it? Yeah, because I can't picture you angry. No, I don't, I don't get, I'm trying to think of the laugh. I mean, I have screamed before. I have screamed in a professional manner. Or like in life or like at home or like with in people and human beings, what pisses you
因为那是他们付钱给你的原因。是的，那是他们付钱给你的部分，非常非常甜美。但是，话虽如此，我想我一直想知道的是，究竟是什么事最让你生气。是的，开始了。我们从这里开始采访。他摆出一副要大干一场的架势。你是说，噢，我充满了爱。我们只想要名字。我们只想要名字。是的。你上次扯着嗓子大喊大叫、把某人大骂一顿是什么时候？是的，因为我无法想象你生气的样子。不，我不会，我不会生气，我在回想那种笑声。我的意思是，我确实大喊过。我曾以专业的方式大喊过。或者像在生活中，或者像在家裡，或者像与人交往时，是什么在惹你
off? I mean, yeah, home, it's, you know, the typical frustrations you have with your children. And for some reason, I'm always checking myself because I'm holding them to some standard that I don't think I was held to. Like I was, I was, I mean, I did well in school, but I still had, you know, my room was a mess and I've never emptied the dishwasher. And but for some reason, I'm just like, you guys, you, it's not that hard. We're asking you to empty the trash. See, if I was your child, I would laugh at that and put the liner back in. Put the liner back. Rewind the trash can. You're not done. It's a two step process. But that, for some reason that I get crazy. And then I'm like, who is this person? Yeah.
生气？我的意思是，是的，在家裡，你知道，就是你对孩子们常有的那些挫败感。不知为何，我总是反省自己，因为我对他们的要求，似乎是我小时候没有达到过的标准。比如我，我的意思是，我在学校表现不错，但我依然，你知道，我的房间一团糟，我从来没有倒过洗碗机。但不知为什么，我就是会觉得：你们，你们，这并不难。我们只是要求你们倒个垃圾。看，如果我是你的孩子，我会对此哈哈大笑，然后再把垃圾袋套回去。把垃圾袋套回去。把垃圾桶倒带。你还没完呢。这是一个两步的过程。但不知为什么，我会为此抓狂。然后我就想：这人是谁？是的。
But I was going to say about holding them to that standard. I, you know, during these weird times we had the other day Archie or 11 year old was on his zoom class. And it turned out he was, he had his camera off and on the side, he was on his iPad playing a video game. So I said to Amy, I said to my ex, I was like, I was like, what are we, he's on the thing and blah, blah, blah. And as I was saying to her, like he's on the, he's on the zoom class, but he's on pause and he's playing a video game beat, beat, beat. I was looking at her and I go, which I probably would have done if given the chance and you probably would have too. And she's like, yeah, I totally know. Yeah, exactly. It was crazy.
但我是想说关于用那个标准要求他们这件事。你知道的，在这个奇怪的时期，前几天我们的11岁儿子阿尔奇在上他的Zoom网课。结果发现他把摄像头关了，在一边用iPad玩电子游戏。所以我对艾米说，我对我的前妻说，我当时就说，我们到底在干嘛，他在弄那个，等等等等。就在我对她说这些的时候，比如他在上Zoom课，但他暂停了，然后在玩电子游戏，哔，哔，哔。我看着她，然后我说，如果我有机会的话，我可能也会这么做，你大概也会。然后她说，对，我完全懂。对，没错。太疯狂了。
I don't, I don't know why. Yeah. I don't know why I go there. But can I have one other thing? I don't on in a work experience kind of bugaboo. Yeah. I don't love the unit publicist experience on a set. Right. And for those listeners who were wondering, there's a lot of times on a production, there's a publicist assigned from the studio and this and that. And they're always playing the game of like so and so is willing to do it if you are and then right guilting you. Yeah. Yeah. And they do, they do these wide circles, right? They just do little drive-bys every once in a while to gauge whether you're in a good mood or a bad mood to just want to kind of run something by you. And, and I'm always, I'm always amazed
我不知道，我不知道为什么。对。我不知道我为什么要扯到那去。不过我能说另一件事吗？关于工作体验这方面的一点小烦恼。对。我不太喜欢片场的那种剧组公关体验。没错。对于那些想知道的听众来说，在剧制中很多时候，会有工作室指派的公关人员，诸如此类。他们总是在玩那种心理战，比如某某如果肯去，那你也得去，然后就开始给你施加负罪感。对。对。而且他们会兜很大的圈子，对吧？他们只是每隔一段时间进行一次小范围的巡视，来试探你是心情好还是心情不好，从而好顺便跟你提点什么事。而且，我总是，我总是感到惊讶
that we want to have 20 journalists visit the set and do a three hour interview while you guys are filming. And I'm always like, but wait, isn't the movie the first priority? And I'm always, I'm always like, absolutely. If we have time. Right. Okay. But when do you think it'll be a good time? You'll have to check with the first AD. Okay. But is there a window? I have no idea. So you're up for it? Yes. If we have time. Okay. Great. So you've signed off. If we have time. Right. And then I love those days when there's no time and you just walk by and you go, I'm sorry, there was no time. Will, what was the thing I remember you were telling me once about kind of felt like the same thing. Somebody
我们居然想让20个记者参观片场，并在你们拍摄的时候进行长达三个小时的采访。而我总是觉得，等等，难道电影不是第一位的吗？而我总是觉得，当然可以，如果我们有时间的话。没错。好的。但你觉得什么时候合适？你得去问第一副导演。好的。但有个时间窗口吗？我完全不知道。所以你愿意吗？是的，如果我们有时间的话。好的。太棒了。那你同意了。只要有时间。没错。然后我喜欢那些根本没时间的日子，你从旁边走过然后说，对不起，完全没时间。威尔，我还记得你以前跟我说过一件事，感觉好像也是这样。有人
said to you, Hey, we're going to do a golf tournament. Tiger Woods is going to come if you're in and like you felt like some of them. Somebody had told Tiger that you were going to play. And it was like, yes, yes. Somehow my dad, my dad became your dad. My dad somehow became a middle man. He was asking me, he had some friend of his down in Newport Beach who came to listen to him play music was like, Hey, so he's talked to Tiger Woods and Tiger Woods is in for it. If you and Tiger Woods play golf together, and they'll raise a bunch of money for charity for another twosome. So you're a foursome together in these two whoever, you know, it goes to the highest bidder to play golf with Will Ferrell and
对你，嘿，我们要办个高尔夫锦标赛。泰格·伍兹会来，如果你参加的话，就像是。有人告诉老虎说你要去打球。就像是，太好了，太好了。不知怎么的，我爸，我爸成了你爸。我爸不知怎么的成了中间人。他问我，他在纽波特海滩有个朋友，来听他弹音乐，然后就说，嘿，他跟泰格·伍兹谈过了，只要你和泰格·伍兹一起打高尔夫，泰格·伍兹就会参加，而且他们会为慈善机构筹集一笔钱，再配对另外两个人。所以你们四个人一组，无论谁，你知道的，出价最高的人可以和威尔·法瑞尔一起打高尔夫，还有
Tiger Woods and that he's already reached out to Tiger and it's good to go. And I was like, well, dad, who is this friend? And how well do you know him? And he seems like a good guy. And, and, and I go, well, you know, a lot of times they'll ask one party before they ask the other. And so maybe I'll check, let me do some research. And for some reason, some way I had some way to check to see if the Tiger camp had ever heard of this special charity golf. Dr. Miller got involved. Exactly. And it turns out, of course, Tiger, I said, dad, guess what, your buddy, Tiger Woods, apparently his team has never heard anything of this. And your friends lying
泰格·伍兹，而且他已经联系过老虎了，一切都安排好了。然后我说，爸，这朋友是谁？你对他了解多少？他看起来像个好人。然后，然后我说，你知道的，很多时候他们会在询问其中一方之前先问另一方。所以也许我问问看，让我做点调查。不知为什么，我不知通过什么途径查到了老虎的阵营是否听说过这个特殊的慈善高尔夫球赛。米勒医生介入了。没错了。结果当然是，老虎，我说，爸，你猜怎么着，你的好朋友泰格·伍兹，他的团队显然根本没听说过这事。你的朋友在对你撒谎
to you. And he was like, how, how could that be? And I said, I know, that's the way the world sometimes works. What kind of music, what kind of music does he play? He's, he's like a old time rock and roll. Really? Yeah. Guitarist? No, he's piano, sax, Hammond B3 organ.
然后他说，怎么，怎么会这样？我说，我知道，世界有时就是这样运转的。他玩什么音乐，他玩什么音乐？他玩的是那种老式摇滚乐。真的吗？对。吉他手？不是，他弹钢琴、萨克斯、哈蒙德B3风琴。
Wow. Wow. Yeah. Let's hear it for the Hammond B3. That's amazing. But yeah, that was my Tiger Woods story. I just, I always loved that idea, though. I've thought about that so many times, the idea of like, so many, when they go like, Hey, we want you to do this thing and so and so
哇。哇。太棒了，为哈蒙德B3鼓掌。太厉害了。不过，对，这就是我的泰格·伍兹故事。我只是，我一直很喜欢那个想法。我曾多次想到过那个想法，就是有很多时候，当他们说，嘿，我们想让你做这件事，某某还有
and so and so we're doing it. And I always think back to that story of like, and I'll go, well, why don't you make sure that so and so, and so it's, that's how I found myself on an island with Marie Osmond and Kurt Cameron, you know? Oh boy. I got asked to play in another charity golf tournament by a friend, assuming that I was going to play with the person I know, right, only to show up and be placed with four strangers. And these guys were like in it to win it. And they're like, Hey, hope you're pretty good.
某某某某都在做。我总是回想起那个故事，然后我会说，嗯，你为什么不确保某某和某某在呢，这就是我怎么发现自己和玛丽·奥斯蒙德还有库尔特·卡梅隆孤男寡女待在一个岛上的，你知道吗？天哪。我被一个朋友邀请去参加另一个慈善高尔夫锦标赛，他以为我会和我认识的人同组，对吧，结果一到那儿却被分给四个陌生人。这几个家伙简直是冲着赢来的。他们说，嘿，希望你打得挺好。
Did you end up playing? Yeah, I had to play this entire 18 holes with these four guys. And they wanted to show you how good they were, right? A hundred percent. They're like, we hope you're good because we win this thing every year. And you better be funny. And you're, well, and I was, it was early SNL days. So they kind of had heard of me, maybe not. And they're like, is that show still on the air? I didn't know people watched
你最后真的去打了吗？对，我不得不和这四个家伙打完整整18个洞。他们想向你展示他们有多厉害，对吧？百分之百。他们说，我们希望你打得好，因为我们每年都赢这个比赛。而且你最好讲笑话很好笑。然后你，嗯，而且那是我在周六夜现场（SNL）早期的日子。所以他们大概听说过我，也许没有。然后他们说，那个节目还在播吗？我都不知道有人看
it. Yeah, it's sweet. He sounds sweet. And then I literally, we, we were supposed to be a banquet afterwards. And I said, guys, I'm going to go put my clubs in my car and I'll meet you back inside. Just move home. And did we win? Yes, we won even despite you really, you didn't stick around for the trophy. I didn't stick around. That's strong. Yeah.
它。对，他人真好。他听起来人很好。然后我字面意思上，我们，我们本该在赛后参加一个宴会，我对大伙说，伙计们，我去把球杆放进车里，然后在里面跟你们碰头。直接回家了。我们赢了吗？赢了，尽管有你的拖累，你居然没留下来拿奖杯。我没留下来。够强硬。对。
So as we say goodbye to you and this, and this pandemic day, what, what, what do you do the rest of the day? Well, let's see. It's three in the afternoon. I'm going to go, I might go, I might go walk our dogs, peanut and Cosmo, right? So that's with a mask. They'll be with a mask. I'm going to do a sweep through the house to find where all the devices have been hidden because these kids are liars and thieves. And so I'll do a sweep and, and then we'll start talking about, we, we start talking about what we're
所以当我们向你告别，在这个大流行病的日子里，接下来的时间，你打算做点什么？好吧，让我想想。现在是下午三点。我要去，我可能会去，我可能会去遛我们的狗，皮纳特和科斯莫，对吧？所以要戴着口罩。它们会戴着口罩。我要把房子彻底搜查一遍，找出所有被藏起来的电子设备，因为这群小鬼又爱撒谎又爱偷东西。所以我要进行一次大搜查，然后我们会开始讨论，我们每天中午左右就开始讨论
making for dinner at around noon every day. So we'll have to start. You got to build a day around that. And then it's sleep by eight. Yeah. Jason, have you done, or will, or Sean, well, not to your kids, but maybe to Scotty, have you ever done a thing where you go, you're so had it with the devices? I've threatened during this pandemic, a minimum of a hundred times to throw the devices in the pool. Yes. I said, this iPad is going in the bottom of the pool. If I see it on one more time.
晚上做什么晚饭。所以我们得开始。你得围绕这个来规划这一天。然后八点钟睡觉。对。杰森，你有没有，或者说威尔，或者肖恩，好吧，不是对你们的孩子，也许是对斯科蒂，你们有没有做过那种事情，就是你对电子设备实在是忍无可忍了？在这场大流行期间，我威胁过至少一百次要把电子设备扔进游泳池。是的。我说，如果我再看到这个iPad一次，它就要沉到游泳池底了。
Yeah. Yeah. But then you quickly realize all that means is more work for you. Yeah. Yeah. True. I did throw my, my 13 year old Matias' phone out the window. You did. Drive all of us driving. But it was a real slow crawl. And I, I picked a target area where I knew we could find it later. And I just chucked it out the window and hit this
对。对。但接着你很快就会意识到，这一切意味着给你自己带来更多的工作。对。对。没错。我确实把我的13岁儿子马蒂亚斯的手机扔出过窗外。你真的扔了。开车的时候我们都在开车。但当时车开得非常慢。而且我挑了一个目标区域，我知道我们稍后能找回它。我直接把它扔出窗外，砸中了这个
bush. And he literally was like, what is wrong with you? And he was so shocked that I actually did it. And typical true to form we pulled over. He's like, I can't believe it. Burst into tears, went back to, to look for the phone. He's like, I can't find it. I can't find it. I walked right up to the bush. I'm like, here it is. It's right here. And so that was a great little shot across the bow. What you're capable of, right? Don't mess. What I'm capable of, but it hasn't been much of a deterrent. Yeah.
灌木丛。他简直就像是，你有毛病吧？他太震惊了我会真的这么做。而且符合一贯的表现，我们靠边停车了。他说，我简直不敢相信。当场嚎啕大哭，回去找手机。他说，我找不到，我找不到。我径直走到灌木丛前，我说，在这呢，就在这。所以这是一个很好的敲山震虎的小举动。让你知道我能干出什么事，对吧？别惹
So. Well, Will Ferrell, thank you for being here with us. We love you. You're our comedy hero. Thanks, you guys. So much fun. Can't thank you enough. Very, very nice of you. Oh, Willie. Bye, guys. Love you, buddy.
我能干出什么事，不过这并没有起到多大的威慑作用。对。那么。好吧，威尔·法瑞尔，谢谢你今天能来和我们在一起。我们爱你。你是我们的喜剧英雄。谢谢你们，伙计们。太有趣了。感激不尽。非常非常感谢你们。哦，威利。拜拜，伙计们。爱你，兄弟。
Bye, Will. Thank you. Guys, that was so fun. How awesome is he? He literally is one of my favorite people in the whole world. And I was a little starstruck there for the first few minutes, but God, he puts you at ease. Doesn't he? What a nice guy. You were starstruck when I came on? Or when he was on? Oh, sorry. Arnett. Oh.
拜拜，威尔。谢谢你。伙计们，刚才太有趣了。他有多棒？他简直是我全世界最喜欢的人之一。头几分钟我还有点追星的紧张感，但天哪，他让你感觉非常放松。不是吗？真是个好人。我来的时候你追星紧张了吗？还是他来的时候？哦，抱歉。阿内特。哦。
Oh, sorry. When Arnett was, yeah. Sure. Good for you, dude. Good for you. Dude, I'm just like, I'm a regular guy. I'm very approachable. Ferrell is the best, isn't he? I had the honor and pleasure and good fortune to, to work on a couple of things with him. And they were some of my fondest memories because most of the time we just screwed around. And it's one of those guys who you go, oh, no wonder you're a superstar because everybody
哦，抱歉。阿内特在的时候，对。当然。真为你骄傲，老兄。真为你骄傲。老兄，我只是，我是一个普通人。我非常平易近人。法瑞尔是最棒的，对吧？我有幸、有荣幸、有运气跟他一起合作过好几次。那些是我最美好的回忆之一，因为大部分时间我们都在瞎胡闹。他就是那种让你觉得，哦，难怪你是超级巨星，因为每个人
wants to work with you because you're one of the nicest people in the business and incredibly talented, right? Yeah. He's got, he's got that, as you know, you guys know, he's got that sort of that natural timing that you cannot learn. You just have it or you don't. And he has got it in spades in ways that are, he's got that thing that makes him, he's so surprising too. Yeah, always. He just surprises you with stuff. It's just awesome. Is there anything you guys learned about him that you didn't know?
都想跟你合作，因为你是业内最好的人之一，而且才华横溢，对吧？对。他拥有，他拥有那种，正如你们所知，你们都知道的，他拥有那种你无法学到的天生节奏感。你就是有或者没有。而他这方面的天赋极其丰厚，有着那种让他，他也总是那么出人意料。对，总是这样。他总是能用各种东西给你惊喜。真是太棒了。关于他，有什么你们以前不知道的，是你们刚刚了解到的吗？
Certainly about his dad. Yeah. Isn't that interesting? And all the sports journalism stuff that he was excited about early on, right? It's crazy. I've met his dad a few times and I guess I didn't really realize his dad was a musician. I don't know how. For the righteous brothers. I mean, that's crazy. Yeah. I did not know he was on Saturday Night Live.
当然是关于他爸爸的。对。是不是很有趣？还有他早期很热衷的所有体育新闻方面的事，对吧？太疯狂了。我见过他爸爸好几次，我猜我之前真的没意识到他爸爸是个音乐家。我怎么会不知道。为了正义兄弟乐队（The Righteous Brothers）。我的意思是，太疯狂了。对。我以前不知道他上过《周六夜现场》。
Oh, yeah. You didn't know that. Wow. Mind blown. Yeah. No, you got to go back and look at some of those. You hosted a couple of times while he was on the show, Sean. I don't look behind me. I don't look behind me. I just look forward. Oh, okay. I don't know how that's applicable in this case.
哦，对。你不知道这个。哇。惊掉下巴。对。不，你得回去看看其中的一些节目。在他上节目的时候你客串主持过好几次，肖恩。我不回头看过去。我不回头看过去。我只往前看。哦，好吧。我不知道这在目前这种情况下怎么适用。
Sean, I'm very proud of you that you got, you got Will Ferrell to say, yes, do you have any sort of incriminating photos or does he owe you money or how did you do that? I have a couple. No, I don't have anything. I can't think of anything. Okay. All right, guys. Love you guys. I love you. Hey, guys, I just want to say, bang.
肖恩，我为你感到非常骄傲，你居然能让威尔·法瑞尔说“好”，你手里有什么 incriminating（煽动性/不利）照片吗，还是他欠你钱，你是怎么做到的？我有几个。不，我没有什么。我想不出有什么。好吧。好吧，伙计们。爱你们。我爱你们。嘿，伙计们，我只想说，砰。
Smart. What? Smart. What? What? What? What? What?
聪明。什么？聪明。什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？
What? What? What? What? There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
什么？什么？什么？什么？这一集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。